The Angular framework is very
relaxed in how you can use it.
If you just want to use
some of its features and
not the whole framework,
then you totally can.
But to stay organized and
consistent with our apps, we'll use a
project scaffolding tool called Yeoman.
Before we do that let's see how
easy it is to add Angular to
an existing project.
Here's a simple app that lists
some information about a brick.
I want to give customers the ability
to enter a number of bricks and
calculate how much it'll cost.
This is a simple request and can easily
be done with Vanilla JavaScript.
But let's see how easy it is to
do with Angular from scratch.
First we need to link to
Angular in the project.
Then to bootstrap Angular,
we need to include an Angular specific
attribute called ng-app
on the body element.
Now Angular will run.
Awesome, except we're not
really seeing anything.
Angular is actually working.
We just haven't told it to do anything.
To actually see something, we need to
add some special code that Angular will
use to display the information.
In the index file is an input field for
the user to select how many
bricks they want to purchase.
And here's a section for
the cart that will show the total price.
But how do we get these two
sections linked together?
We'll look at this in more detail when
we get to the section on directives.
But I'll add this Angular
attribute to the input field.
Then I'll use this same value
down here in the calculation.
Looking at the browser,
we now have an interactive app.
Granted, this is a very simple app,
but isn't it incredible what
we've accomplished without even
opening a single JavaScript file?
So I just added the code directly
to the existing index file.
That's fine for small projects,
but if you're app grows or if multiple
developers are working on an app,
you'll probably want some
organization and consistency.
Let's look at Yeoman to see one way
professional Angular projects are built.